ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht aber ich
merke immer mehr meinem eigenen umfeld
und auch mit freunden mit denen ich
spreche fast jeder oder jede kennt
jemand der zumindest die bewohner
maßnahmen kritisiert der
vielleicht auch für initiativen wie
querdenker oder so spannend findet oder
der sorge einer verschwörung ideologie
irgendwie so ein bisschen zugeneigt ist
jetzt nach der eskalation am rande der
demo in berlin findet die nächste große
demo in konstanz statt also ganz im
süden von deutschland und wir wollen
jetzt einfach mal hinfahren und uns
einfach mal angucken wenn wir da treffen
können wieso die menschen dahin was ihre
forderungen sind und inwiefern wir mit
denen auch ins gespräch kommen können
[Musik]
ja jetzt also konstanz hier hinter mir
sieht man schon die erste gegen dem man
muss auch ganz klar sagen 83 prozent der
befragten zumindest im september
politbarometer sind gegen die anti
coroner demonstration und finden die
maßnahmen der regierung überwiegend
sinnvoll
jetzt gehts heute trotzdem darum einfach
mal zu gucken wer hier sein wird und
dann später bei den querdenker vor allen
dingen und ich bin einfach super
gespannt wie das für mich willst hier
als journalistin zu sein weil ich schon
diverse berichte kenne von kolleginnen
und kollegen die da auch angefeindet
wurden angegangen und deswegen bin habe
ich schon auch respekt jetzt hier vor
dieser aufgabe und damit einfach sehr
sehr gespannt was wir heute auf uns
zukommt tatsächlich werden in den ersten
gesprächen direkt viele klischees
erfüllt wir werden teilweise
abenteuerliche dinge erzählt später
lerne ich auch andere teilnehmer innen
kennen aber zum start
er schlägt mich das jetzt einfach darum
widerstand zu leisten gegen das was hier
abgeht ist einfach nicht gut gespielt
und ich möchte dass sich das ändert bin
ich ein ganz dummes gefühl in meinem
bauch wo es hingeht und ich möchte nicht
dass meine kinder und alle kinder und
alle menschen erleben menschen bei
sollte system hineingeführt haben wir
leben im faschismus und es könnte sich
in der diktatur entwickeln würden wie
das so zusammen das ist für mich schon
irgendwie aus dem becken dann also was
ist für sie ihr hauptantriebe absolute
hauptantrieb die hose
die lückenhafte berichterstattung muss
ja noch nicht mal gelogen sein sondern
einfach nur was weggelassen die
lückenhafte berichterstattung in den
mainstreammedien die gleichgeschalteten
also es gibt so viele themen die werden
einfach gar nicht angesprochen
wir waren erst in dem krieg gegen den
terror da hat man doch angst gemacht
sondern weil die klimakatastrophe hat
man uns angst gemacht jetzt einmal eine
pandemie da macht man uns angst so ich
hätte ganz gern mal in der andere
gefühlslage einfach mal wieder ein
fröhliches miteinander und nicht im
gegeneinander werkstatt und er glaubt
dass du glaubst an die runde scheibe du
glaubst an die an die an die an die
runde erde und du glaubst an die an die
flache erde so da denke ich mir das ist
von mir aus kann der daran glauben und
der daran solange die beiden sich einig
sind dass wieder zusammen drauf um
laufen kann doch damit arbeiten oder
manche leute die haben ähnliche man sich
die meisten nicht
was führt sie dann jetzt dazu zu sagen
mir ist das jetzt so wichtig mir brennt
das so unter den nägeln ich kann es
nicht mehr zitieren ich gehe dafür auf
die straße
das ist die wahrheit also die die
eigentlich schon vorher wird kann
möglicherweise auch den politikern
bekannt war und dann spürt jetzt so
unrecht gerechtigkeit ist da ist die
ganze verletzten aufgenommen hat und die
unwissenheit von vielen bürgern die sich
einfach nicht haben weil jetzt
wahrscheinlich youtube renner sagt immer
so youtube hatte schon gemacht werde ich
sage video hat mich aufgeklärt ich
arbeite jetzt hier im auftrag der
öffentlich-rechtlichen
was habe ich für ein interesse daran ihn
irgendwas falsch ist
ich vermute ich weiß es ja nicht warum
aber deswegen können wir jetzt aber
miteinander das interessiert mich ja
weil die sagen ja sie glauben so wie
hier werden gespräche oft unterbrochen
schnell bilden sich gesprächs trauben
irgendwann ist es ja alles sie vermissen
kritik an den corona maßnahmen in den
medien halb verhalten fake news
verschwörungs ideologien stehen im raum
alle betonen sie wünschen sich einen
austausch wirklich eine chance dazu hat
man selten
gar nichts mehr aber was wirklich
permanent thema ist sie wollen nicht mit
nazis in einen topf geworfen werden
fühlen sich diffamiert
[Musik]
insgesamt waren an dem wochenende 29
veranstaltungen und demos in konstanz
angemeldet das große highlight sollte
eine menschenkette für frieden und
freiheit der querdenker um den bodensee
werden
viele menschen waren aber auch in der
stadt um gegen die korona kritiker zu
demonstrieren
aber
also man weiter was dahinter steht und
das ist eben der der kontext in dem mit
demonstration er gemacht und auch diese
gäste die es nicht in ordnung was ist
deine größte sorge jetzt aktuell meine
größte angst ist eigentlich nicht und
kann dann eigentlich passen eben diese
stimmung im land geführt und
andere größere menschenmengen
ich bin ersten und ich mache mir sorgen
über den dunklen ich mache mir sorgen
dass wir die patienten die da auf uns
zukommen könnten
selbst noch mal richtig fahrt aufnimmt
nicht alle adäquat behandeln können und
jetzt haben wir heute auch schon mit
mehreren querdenkerin gesprochen die
sagen es gibt aber auch diverse ärzte
die widersprechen dem
die sagen das alles überhaupt nicht so
schlimm was würden sie dem empfiehlt man
die mehrzahl der wissenschaftler aktuell
die ganz überwiegende mehrzahl wie hält
das für 100 büros für gefährlich und dem
würde ich mich anschließen im sinne der
wissenschaftlichkeit auf der medizin
ich würde denen entgegnen das muss sehr
schnell ist wenn sie recht haben ich
würde mich freuen wenn das virus setzen
sind hat sechs standorten und oder alles
ganz harmlos ausgeht
aber ich fürchte das ist nicht so ist
denn dann stehen wir leider an
vorderster front und darüber mache ich
mir sorgen
sie würden sagen sie würden dann gerne
auch einfach mit denen ins gespräch
kommen und sind deswegen heute auch hier
ich habe heute schon mit einigen
menschen die auf der anderen demo seite
stehen gesprochen und mehrere menschen
angefahren wird und wir hatten das schon
gespräche und wir verlieren wir jetzt
auch nicht alles umgangston
alex von den querdenkern hat uns
zugehört er vermisst eine debatte über
die maßnahmen und will erklärungen warum
von der politik nicht diskutiert worden
ob das sinnvoll sondern es wird einfach
raus wir müssen wir mussten den
lochkarten
warum wird es nicht öffentlich
diskutiert mit kritikern medical
solutions die also nicht
wir haben auch argumenten genauso wie
die befürworter des lotter uns die haben
auch gute argumente und diese argumente
müssen mal zusammenkommen damit diese
die serie c klassen auf vielleicht mal
auf einen nenner kommen oder sich über
wieder etwas einig sind
also ich glaube daher sparen hat das
gesagt bisher wurde diese entscheidung
zur nicht mehr drin
warum naja weil er ganz klar sagt mit
dem jetzigen wissensstand wenig mehr
infektion und mehr euro sowohl infektion
und so weiter und so fort das heißt wenn
alle sich an den abstand halten an die
masken halten dann ist das nicht mehr
notwendig den einzelhandel
beispielsweise so einschränken wie es
damals war
also die situation hier ist wirklich
sehr unübersichtlich weil gerade noch
eine gegendemo da unten können sich die
querdenkerin oder die menschen die bei
der friedens kette teilnehmen wollen
anmelden
hier geht's jetzt weiter und wir sagen
ach so leute ich will jetzt nicht bei
dem falschen mit gehen wo man sich
überhaupt hin und es bilden sich immer
mal wieder kleine grüppchen die
irgendwie miteinander diskutieren aber
insgesamt ist die ganze situation
ziemlich unübersichtlich
nachmittags bildet sich dann die
menschenkette das sind die friedlichen
bilder die sie erzeugen wollen mit uns
sprechen will aber erst mal niemand
es werden sogar augen verdreht dann
entdecke ich eine junge frau mit
mundschutz
sie ist über 900 kilometer an den
bodensee gereist um in dieser kette zu
stehen
das finde ich krass es gab schon immer
zu allen themen verschiedene meinungen
das gefühl das ist eigentlich fast immer
ganz gut geklappt hat dass da auch die
anderen meinung mal gehört wurden und
dass man dann auch selber darüber
nachdenken konnte und jetzt finde ich es
ist alles sehr in eine richtung und
alles andere wird so komplett
abgeriegelt und gesprächen und ja ich
glaube das ist ein ganz ganz großer
fehler der politik gewesen da sie nur in
eine richtung zu gehen und alle die halt
auch anderes sagen als idioten zu
bezeichnen oder sonstiges weil dass
menschen einfach das gefühl gibt dass
sie nicht gesehen werden dass sie nicht
gehört werden
und das ist in einer demokratie glaube
ich ganz ganz wichtig dass man eben alle
menschen hört und sieht und ihn auch das
gefühl gibt dass sie ihre stimme was
zählt und das wäre dir mehr ein anliegen
als sie zu sagen die maßnahmen müssten
aufgehoben werden oder hast du das
gefühl du es irgendwie durch masken
tragen oder das eintragen weil sachen
irgendwie eingeschränkt wie es geht mir
wirklich in erster linie darüber dass
mir diese offene diskurs fehlt die bist
du sie hat so dazugekommen anfang war
ich auch sehr dabei und hab gesagt leute
das ist wichtig wir müssen irgendwie
schauen dass wir das irgendwie alles
hier im griff bekommen und habe dann für
mich immer so mehr unstimmigkeiten
festgestellt
sollte diese diese darstellung in den
medien irgendwie weiter verfolgt und
haben doch irgendwie alles ein bisschen
komisch und habe mich dann halt weiter
informiert und bin dann quasi immer
weiter habe ich mich informiert und bin
dann kann sie auch hier zur
friedenskirche zu bekommen und würdest
du jetzt aber schon sagen du guckst du
schon auch noch grundsätzlich öffentlich
rechtlichem recht verstanden haben und
das ist doch total wichtig dass man
nicht jetzt die andere seite nur noch
komplett in eine richtung geht es ist ja
genauso schlimm wenn man einfach nur
noch eine meinung hört es ist nie gut
man sollte immer sich fortlaufend von
beiden seiten davon den ganzen seiten
dieser verfügt hinsichtlich also weiß
informieren
es ist einfach eine extrem belastende
situation wenn man halt irgendwie
unglücklich ist in der aktuellen lage
und das hat äußert kriegt man einfach
extrem viel gegenwind wird wenig
verstanden auf anderer seite und das ist
halt auch wichtig dass man sich hier
gegenseitig so ein bisschen ein ohr
schenkt damit halt vielleicht die leute
die jetzt so enttäuscht und dass sie
schon wütend sind vielleicht ein
bisschen weniger von der enttäuschung
haben und wir bekommen ja so
differenziert sind wenige sie spricht
von liebe aber viele menschen hier sind
wütend sie kritisieren auch nicht nur
die stimmung ist geladen
irgendwie gegen rheda was wird er so an
den kopf geworfen wenn du sitzt hier
wirklich um was quasi gar nicht da gibt
es nicht mehr
jahrhunderts ausgestorben
idiot also
der positive nachricht ist wenn ich also
ich studiert psychologie nicht
erstaunlich dass so negativ mich wundert
es nicht wirklich masken sind hier ein
riesenproblem für viele und die meisten
der angereisten querdenker in bezweifeln
dass krone gefährlich ist sie fordern
ein ende der schutzmaßnahmen ich nenne
jetzt nicht theater
diese maßnahmen weil stellen was mal
sehen
gehen wir mal davon aus dass sind es
sind leute in den richtigen positionen
die wollen nur das beste für uns überall
also durch die ganzen instanzen durch
das haben die gute absichten und sagen
wir wollen die leute schützen
wie lange wollen wir das machen wie
gesagt meine branche ist schon mal weg
da mal sagen ja aber dass wir sterben
weniger leute okay wenn das so ist bin
ich bereit dazu sage ich habe ich nicht
gehabt
das risiko einzugehen alle maßnahmen
aufzuheben um das auszutesten
finden sie nicht das ist ein stück zu
groß ich bin ich auf die welt komme ab
tag eins weiß ich ganz schwer
ich hab das jetzt schon häufiger hat das
leid das gefühl haben sie werden
verarscht wird trifft es für sie auch zu
auf den seiten
und haben sie irgendein gefühl also ich
meine das ist immer schwierig so dass er
zu hinterfragen aber haben sie gefühlt
wären interesse daran haben könnte
ja auf jeden fall aber sind alles
verschwörungstheorien die frau eines
lieber einer aus schlimm ist wenn man
verschwörungstheoretiker ist weil das
ist ein problem das wir mittlerweile
haben das wird er in einem satz genannt
mit nazi entschuldigung also mit nazi
verschwörungstheoretiker idiot co
videospieler sportler sonst hast
ich sage für mich ein paar sachen nicht
zusammen und was würde ich tun
ja ich gucke natürlich nach
informationen die vielleicht mal was
anderes sagen und wie es am ende
wirklich ist ich weiß es nicht sie
wissen es auch nicht
keiner hier weiß es wir wissen es nicht
ich gebe es risiken dem verantwortung
für meine meinung und sage
mag sein dass ich falsch liege und mit
alle auslaufen dürfen wenn ich würde
mich freuen wenn so ist
möglich
überzeugen kann man hier niemanden ich
habe mich aufs zuhören konzentriert bei
der kundgebung gibt es zum teil sehr
fragwürdige reden und schilder die
menschen tragen alle keinen mund nasen
schutz achten aber auf die abstände es
gibt sogar mörth der gekauft wird
an ganz vielen stellen sollen sie
spenden mehr ist hier vieles respekt
natürlich glauben nicht alle hier dass
hinter allem eine böse macht steckt
einiger sind nur verunsichert qualitäten
nachzuvollziehen weil man heutzutage in
den medien gibt einfach so viele
verschiedene informationsquellen und es
ist total schwierig zu unterscheiden was
ist jetzt war nicht wahr was es fällt
nix was sind waren etwas manipuliert was
ist nicht manipuliert da irgendwie den
überblick zu behalten für mich total
schwierig ich habe enge freunde mit
denen kann ich mich nicht mehr
unterhalten die ob jetzt die gemeinde
also die teile die meinung nicht mit mir
aber das ist für mich ist das in ordnung
wenn die die meinung nicht halten für
mich ist nur wichtig mit denen austausch
zu gehen weil für mich ist es genauso
wichtig deren meinung immer wieder zu
hören um mich selbst zu hinterfragen ich
glaube nur so kann man also wenn man
sich selbst immer wieder reflektiert
eine anständige meinung sich bilden
dabei das gefühl es gibt überhaupt keine
bereitschaft einen austausch zu gehen
sondern es wird einfach gesagt nein ich
möchte nicht mit dir sprechen
auch er ist vorsichtig und um dialog
bemüht nach tag eins war ich
einigermaßen ratlos
[Musik]
ganzen tag ist wer zuerst mal diese
maske als seit ich weiß nicht wann wird
und auch die ohren
ich bin irgendwie voll mit allen
möglichen eindrücken hier und ich habe
schon am allermeisten das gefühl es gibt
viele menschen die nicht mit uns
sprechen wollen weil ich sage dass ich
im auftrag des zdf arbeitet es gibt
viele menschen die mit uns sprechen
wollen und ganz laut das verkaufen
wollen was sie denken und gar nicht so
genau darauf eingehen wollen und ich für
fragen gestellt habe aber dass sich
menschen so krass eingeschränkt fühlen
und tatsächlich auch manchmal irgendwie
sehr differenziert irgendwie auch angst
haben um demokratie und meinungsfreiheit
oder sagen sie können sich nicht mehr
äußern
das finde ich schon erschreckend also
das ist schon das was mich irgendwie so
am meisten beschäftigt insgesamt recht
einfach und ich muss echt sagen ich habe
einen riesenrespekt da vorher draußen
beitrag zu machen daraus ein stück zu
machen weil ich ganz genau weiß
viele menschen werden sich trotzdem
nicht so dargestellt fühlen oder sich
nicht so angesprochen fühlen
eigentlich auch unabhängig davon was ich
mache es gibt leute freuen sich dass sie
mal mit mir sprechen können die freuen
sich dass auf sie zugegangen wird die
sagen das ist toll dass ihr hier seid
ihr seid irgendwie nett ihr seid
sympathisch aber ich bin gespannt was
sie dann sagen wenn sie sehen was ich
was ich eine wichtige von berichten also
wirklich gespart
das habe ich ganz kalte verbrauch was zu
essen und was zu trinken
dieser bericht fühlt sich für mich an
wie ein seiltanz ein zusammenschnitt ab
so der äußerung wäre einfacher gewesen
material gäbe es genug
aber darum geht es mir nicht denn ich
finde die ganze situation wenig witzig
mir war wichtig wirklich mit menschen
ins gespräch zu kommen
einfach war das nicht die menschen am
demokratie mobil haben ähnliches erlebt
wie es denn so ein bisher ihre erfahrung
hier vor ort da sich diese pauschal
vorwurf dass unsere medien alle
gleichgeschaltet sein
[Musik]
und das ist tatsächlich sehr
problematisch wie bei eigenen schule
erreichen
zu sagen wir haben eine mediale vielfalt
und 7 uhr die möglichkeit in der
internet zu recherchieren aber sie soll
das passiert immer wieder startet ein
gespräch kommt es oft zu rudelbildung
das hatte nicht das gefühl dass wir eine
verständnisvolle regierung haben die uns
so informiert dass wir das auch
verstehen und dass dann gerne mit und
mit den masten war ja auch ein bisschen
hinten torschützen sie schützen nicht
und bei mir ist es wirklich so dass ich
doch darunter nicht aus seit ich krieg
das hat andere gründe
aber ich bin wirklich als ich dann das
erste mal ohne maske unterwegs war so
angegangen worden dass ich wirklich
gezittert habe und angst hatte und heute
alleine ist eigentlich nur dass ich dann
wieder auf setzte damit ich mache hat
alles nur ganz kurz die schnell
umgeladen
und das ist wirklich von den mitmenschen
aber sehr krass der maske an und man
merkt man erst dann ein außenseiter ich
habe auch viele viele freunde
keiner wurde das mitträgt wenn ich jetzt
nachhaltige sagen wo ich mach doch
einfach mit
und ich bin auch eigentlich kommentiert
gar nicht nur nicht ist es jetzt erst
einmal dass ich auf so ner dem ja und
ich hab mir videos mitgemacht und müssen
weil das ist dieses ungerechte auf
solchen veranstaltungen bestärken sie
sich gegenseitig in ihren ansichten
es bleibt eine gefährliche mischung aus
unzufriedenheit angst medienkritik und
unsicherheit
ich höre oft dieselbe forderung nach
einem runden tisch nach dialog
dabei darf man nicht vergessen fakten
zählen hier meist weniger als das gefühl
und sehr schnell geht es nicht mehr um
corona sondern um systemkritik
[Musik]
es sind nicht vor winken hat sich
tatsächlich immer menschen die hier vor
ort sind
würde ich jetzt nicht als
nationalsozialist bezeichnen es gibt
natürlich viele menschen die aus einem
bürgerlichen rechts steuerlichen
spektrum kommt andererseits verstehe ich
nicht warum kriegt man sich eine demo zu
organisieren und ganz offen kundzutun
dass sexismus rassismus dass faschismus
in jeglicher art homophobie einfach
nicht erwünscht ist und keine plattform
gegeben wird
und da gibt es kein eindeutiges
statement außer dass bei manchen
kundgebungen gesagt wird ja wir wollen
uns davon distanzieren aber es
funktioniert ja nicht werden magazine
verkauft aus dem rechten spektrum die
finden plattform und das sind einfach
viel zu viele indizien dafür dass es
nicht wirklich im interesse dieser
bewegung ist menschen die ein
menschenfreundliches bild haben war sie
nicht eine plattform zu bieten
tja das ist jetzt unsere letzte sendung
hier in konstanter riesenrad zur
belohnung ich sagen ich bin richtig
durch ich würde irgendwie gerne ein
kurzes und schmissiges fazit hier
ausziehen aber ich komme mir mit so
vielen fragen kopf und mit solchen
gedanken aus das ist wirklich schwierig
zu sagen wer hier überhaupt für was ist
die meisten menschen können auch sehr
schwer darauf eine kurze antwort geben
und was ich mitnehme das ist zum teil
gelingt irgendwie gespräche zu führen
was auch eingefordert wird und es über
schön oder irgendwie auch schön dass ein
vertrauen entgegengebracht wird und dass
ich mich damals schon so heulen wie wie
viele menschen überhaupt kein vertrauen
mehr haben
berichterstattung in sophie lamerdinger
und so viele alternativen medien
irgendwie mehr glauben schenken und das
ist für mich echt beängstigend und da
bin ich wirklich gespannt sie sich so
etwas entwickelt und wünsche mir einfach
die offenheit die von demonstrierenden
die eingefordert wird dass sie diese
offenheit irgendwie auch den menschen
gegenüber bringen die versuchen mit
ihnen ins gespräch zu kommen weil das
ist auch nicht immer der fall man
kontinenten mit sachargumenten durch und
zum teil werden fragen die man fragt
auch nicht beantwortet haben die
menschen hier wollen einfach unfassbar
viel los werden muss so ein druck drauf
und so viel emotionalität und ja man
kann natürlich auch in frage stellen
welches selbst wenn er unten dann nachts
raus bestehen wird weil sie viele darf
und dann nur noch stärker in die ecke
drängen gleichzeitig muss man auch sagen
man muss darüber sprechen können dass
versucht wird diese bewegungen von
rechts zu vereinnahmen
mich besorgt was sich da zusammenbraut
zurück im büro frage ich mich wie wir
als gesellschaft damit umgehen sollten
darüber habe ich mit pierre lamberti
gesprochen die zu verschwörungs
ideologien forscht räder oder jeder
kennt in seinem umkreis jemanden der
sagen wir mal im ansatz kritisch ist der
vielleicht schon ein bisschen weiter
vielleicht auch sich in richtung einer
organisation informiert oder der sogar
schon ein verschwörungs erzählung in die
an glaubhaft corona das verstärkt oder
ist nur jetzt sichtbar
das war vorher auch schon da aber es
wurde glaube ich wollte ich entweder
nicht ernst genommen irgendwie als
schuldigkeit abgetan belächelt und war
eben nicht so relevant wie die eigene
wahrnehmung
und ich glaube das hat es durch bewohner
noch mal stark erinnert dass die
gesellschaftliche sensibilität jetzt
viel größer ist dass man merkt das hat
konsequenzen das macht was diese
menschen verhalten sich anders durch
diese ideologie die sie haben aber es
ist natürlich auch weit verbreitet also
wenn man sich die studien anguckt würde
ich sagen also ungefähr so zwischen 25
und 30 prozent eine verschwörung
erzählung über oder glauben ob social
media und youtube ist schlimmer machen
kann man nur schwer sagen weil es keine
langzeitstudien dazu gibt
man kann sich das angucken was sonst die
forschung so zeigt und da ist es so dass
zb eine einmalige konfrontation mit
einer verschwörung erzählung im labor
schon dazu führt dass menschen
misstrauischer werden muss die weniger
bereit sind sich impfen zu lassen dass
sie sich mehr aus dem demokratischen
system zurückziehen das heißt vielleicht
selbst ist selbst wenn sie nicht die
ganze beschwörung erzählungen den ganzen
mythos glauben bleibt etwas davon zurück
wenn man jetzt bedenkt wie oft menschen
in sozialen medien mit solchen inhalten
konfrontiert werden
cactus sicherlich ein effekt habe ich
auch das gefühl es gibt schon auch noch
menschen die da sehr differenziert sind
und sagen sie schauen noch diverse dinge
an aber fühlen sich nicht wahrgenommen
fühlen sich in eine rechte ecke gedrängt
und sagen ich spreche mit menschen die
sind ja alle supernett uns geht es um
frieden und freiheit und aber wir werden
nicht gehört
also ich glaube auch diesen
demonstrationen geht tatsächlich häufig
ins beschwörung theologische und ich
meine es gibt natürlich ja auch den
banken es gibt unter dem button darüber
ob maßnahmen verschärft werden sollen
oder nicht wie mit dem thema schule
umgegangen werden soll also die sind ja
schon durchaus da
ich glaube was da passiert ist dass die
menschen das gefühl haben dass ihre
meinung ist wir haben vielleicht das zu
früh stigmatisiert auch eine form von
kritik an den corona maßnahmen behaltet
die versprochenen demokratischen diskurs
ich halte auch hier dass man wenn man
diskutiert was so einem anime mit
menschen macht besser maßen haben hier
wichtig sind
ich glaube aber nicht dass eine größere
debatte
das verhindert hätte was wir gerade
sehen das war ehrlich gesagt ich glaube
für alle expertinnen sicherlich nicht im
detail aber im grossen ganzen relativ
erwarte dass das ein großes thema werden
wird eben weil der verschwörungs glaube
immer verstärkt und in krisenzeiten bei
gerade pandemien sich eignen
verschwörungs erzählungen darum zu
spinnen wir haben nicht eine konkrete
sichtbare gefahr sondern eine abstrakte
unsichtbare die ist für menschen ganz
häufig schwer zu greifen also das seien
themen dass die kommen würden mich nicht
bei hundert ich glaube dass er
verschiedene punkte hier wichtig sind
zum einen ist es so
das in der vergangenheit häufig so die
idee bei es gibt diese besorgten bürger
man müsse ihnen nur zuhören und dann
würden sich gesellschaftliche probleme
auflösen das hat nicht funktioniert und
es wird auch hier nicht funktionieren
stattdessen für nicht wichtiger dass man
sich als gesellschaftliche normen und
werte festlegt dass man sagt das und das
und rote linien und wenn die
überschritten werden wird eine person
dafür auch kritisiert dementsprechend
seien demos wo eben auch extreme
ansichten und verschwörungs ideologien
raum finden nicht der richtige ort für
kritik es gibt nach sechs monaten
pandemie einiges an legitimer kritik
aber wenn sich bewegungen von fakten und
von den säulen der demokratie entfernen
ist das gefährlich und kann die
gesellschaft zu ersetzen
wir müssen uns alle überlegen wie wir
damit umgehen wollen
eine einfache lösung gibt es nicht
[Musik]